I decided not to concentrate on just one
championship because then you just
killed someone you know instead we're
gonna have one game from different
championship games that have some effect
on either me or the audience at large so
some of you are really into just might
be disappointed because they're
relatively modern but I still think you
could see this game again and again I've
seen it more than once and still stay
alive
so this is the decisive game from the
match between top olive and Arnaud in
Sofia 2010 game 12 and none is in a
must-win situation if he wants to retain
his self just retain his title because
right now it's 2 2 the score in the
mattress to 2 withdraws and this is the
game game 12 so he is playing black I
don't think that he came into this game
really thinking that he's gonna win the
game maybe he thought that after a
draught is going to be some sort of tie
breaks or but he played in my opinion
and and I know that that other strong
players agree one of the most
strategically perfect games that have
been played in recent in modern times
really perfect game ok so without
further ado ok we're gonna go with this
opening the annotations by the way if
you see in the annotations and lines are
by no less than onigiri who today beat
mvl and qualified to the next phase at
the World Cup very strong player so
again many possibilities I mentioned
Bishop f4 is mentioned Bishop g5 ok 86
Bishop h4 castles III and again this is
a famous position many moves are known
he decided to play 94 which is known as
the Lasker variation other moves that
are worth mentioning our Tata cover
would be six which is very very popular
by lots of players including but not
limited to people like Nigel short like
when he was a world candidate and you
could play C 697 there are a little more
quiet so 94 Lasker's idea
and now we understand why eight-six was
played if the bishop was still on g5
then the bishop would not be obligated
to trade he could just play Bishop f4
which could be a little bit unknowing
when the bishop still stay because the
bishop right now this Bishop is
definitely better than this Bishop
that's why you're trying to relieve some
of the pressure so now of course the
bishop has to go here it makes no sense
to play bishop here when the knight can
just take it Queen takes a seven and
again modern times he played the move
rook c1 Queen c2 is an atom of this
popular in the old days the only
variation that was really tried was pawn
takes d5 and of course the knight has to
take on c3 otherwise even lose the pond
so pawn takes d5 pawn takes Knight takes
c3 pawn takes c3 pawn takes d5 and even
the white tried to prove an advantage
with times it was proven that Black
Widow keeps completely complete control
of the position they've tried c4 they've
tried other moves it's really a safe
line for black even this time is very
very hard to challenge this game will
serve as an example so rook to see one
c6 again you have to pay attention here
you cannot play a move like let's say
Knight B g7 C takes d5 and the pawn on
c7 can have some real issues you can see
that right 97 see d5 if you take back
you just lose it if you take the knight
first I'll take with my rock and the
pawn on c7 is embarrassed so c6 and now
again you can see analysis there are
many many variations kind of funny I'm
looking at this game because I was
preparing one of my students at the
World Youth for exactly this kind of
variation and okay the opening again the
point is not to teach the opening the
point is to show you the variation the
the game so Bishop e2 is very okay
Knight takes c3 again we trading some
pieces rook takes D takes c4 again the
main idea here this is the this is the
point Bishop takes 97 okay of course if
rook takes again it's very very similar
Bishop takes
97 castles and now he played the move B
6 e 5 was the old move to try to get
again of course just to just to say two
words about this position the problem
child is Bishop c8 the question is how
are we going to get this guy into play
right now it has no moves is blocked by
the knight also you have to be a little
smart about where you put this Knight so
one of the music was tried was 'if I've
to release the pressure and of course
white is not going to take it was gonna
sit and wait and again white enjoys a
slight advantage in space and better
development at least for now more pieces
are out the rook is already active and
this Bishop is sleepy while this one is
out so now we try b6 again a new idea a
relative bail it was a new idea Bishop
to d3 immediately taking the pawn on c6
c5 striking at the center very very
important Bishop a4 again because in
this position what black really wants to
do is to play Bishop d7 and have a
really nice Bishop on the long diagonal
so from being a really bad Bishop all of
a sudden you put it on the long diagonal
it becomes much better than this Bishop
so Bishop b4 trying to disrupt that plan
rook b8 and now Queen a4 and again a
very interesting move but Queen c2 again
a theoretical position and this was the
line that Topalov was expecting against
our prepared for and in this position
anam came with a really nice idea this
is what the game really begins and
leaves a real really impression and when
you first look at it you think wow this
is a move that maybe a computer can come
up with but a human looks like he's
gonna look in for a second and just say
no and he plays Knight f6 fantastic this
is just a really great move now what to
do the knight is attacking the pressure
obviously I'm dying to take this bishop
complaint it should be seven if I get to
some position where I get to just take
this Bishop Queen takes Bishop e7 on the
long diagonal not to mention that I can
even take this
nice Olivia porn well of course black is
gonna be just much better so what to do
he took on c5 another option was to save
the bishop going this way but now of
course by doing that of course not the
c6 square is occupied by a bishop so I
can easily take save my pawn by taking
90 eggs of course a second ago I
wouldn't even dream of doing it with the
bishop back on f3 because the knight c6
will just ruin me
but now the bishop is occupying that
square so I can do it and now II 5 and
you can see that black is looking in the
position claiming to have absolutely no
problem whatsoever the knight doesn't
have c6 that he was hoping for so he has
to go somewhere then the bishop can just
come out and black has solved all his
opening problems again not to win but at
that level you just want to survive you
just wanna not be worse and here he
achieved it
so in our game he is basically picking
up the gauntlet by taking on c5 he's
saying okay show me
so of course Knight takes c6 and in
Knight takes d4 Queen takes pawn takes
e5 so obviously a deal was made one side
gave up is very good Bishop white in
return he charged a complete mess up of
the black pawn structure and this is
again the question that probably wasn't
well answered before this game because
it looked like well I can easily
overcome one bishop when this point is
going to be a problem forever
I can easily defend my stuff but as this
game will show blacks activity
completely outweighs the pawn structure
compromise and let's see how it's done
okay let's see it some variations first
of b3 Bishop d7 and now again well
there's a million moves I'm not going to
show you all of them because we only
have 40 minutes or not ten hours but
like Queen a for Bishop f3 takes rook d8
again great activity the rook is coming
to detail row here route d2
and you can tell that the black activity
Peter says you know do whatever you want
to the C pawn I have the D file
threatening roof d1 I'm also interested
in the pond on a2 in some variations so
after g3 you know again black has
definitely more than enough comfort for
the weakness of the structure so in the
game the problem was trying something
else
after takes and he played Queen City
okay he is directly saying okay I'm
defending the pawn on b2 and I'm looking
very hungrily at the pawn on c5 Bishop
e7 completely ignoring the pawn
correctly because obviously after taking
the pawn taking the night the King said
is ruined and now the pawn comes back
with interest after route b2 and if you
don't take I'm just going to take more
pawns and otherwise if you take I take
on c5 and when you look at the two
positions only block can be happy
because his pawn structure is just
intact and the white one is not so in
our game he played might be to also
another variation that is mentioned is
if efore f5 again very aggressive
anything and everything to open up that
bishop so yeah so in the game he went 92
and again this is probably the the
position the top olive had in his mind
thinking okay the bishop is very nice
but I'm moving my knight and in the
meantime I'm going to keep you super
busy with that si bon so now rook d8
again a free developing move based on
the tactic that rook c5 rook d2 again
doesn't quite work out and the problem
is probably starting to appreciate that
again
position we be speaking yet the pawn is
weak and yes white is all over it but as
we know well in just sometimes the
position the positional stuff is being
marked by tactics and here the black
tactics just one move after another make
sure that the pawn structure doesn't
have any significance or at least not
overwhelming significance so pawn to f3
trying to pacify that Bishop a little
bit sooner only has to make that move
because you cannot play that Bishop
every move you have to think of
happens on g2 right all of a sudden
there's going to be a queen takes g5 or
a bishop takes g2 you can't calculate
every move
what if that happens so f3 very logical
Bishop a6 very very concrete attacking
the rook and again he has several
choices if you would have just played
rook c1 playing aliens gun opposite the
porn then Queen d7 immediately looking
at the pawn and the night and when the
knight moves simply c4 okay also Bishop
d3 is equal mentioned as equal if you
want to just do that about c4 and
nothing to worry about
okay so again completely equal position
according to the computer so he played
rook F 2 and I have to tell you that
that all those combinations of moves
make the boy position a little bit
suspicious
he is really pushing hard and somehow
he's slowly slowly slowly drifting into
a worse position but for now he is not
in danger yet now another idea was to
play rook d5 first luring efore and then
playing rook d7 but okay he decided to
play rugby seven at once again the
question is should upon beyond III on e4
let's keep this in mind for the rest for
the advance of the game and now g3 okay
rook d8 king g2 and now again notice
that in this position vichy
typically to vichy he is not making any
committal moves he doesn't want to play
e5 he doesn't apply h5 he doesn't want
to create anything you just holds the
position maintains it and let the part
of the kind of challenges too hard to
say okay you have white our last game in
the match are you gonna push for it or
not and so he plays just Bishop to d3
very very nice so now again some lines
are given by Gary he mentions Queen a
for Bishop e5 could just be an equal
line just attacking the the Queen and if
takes rook takes D - okay another way to
play Queen g5
hitting everything and here 94 would be
equal after Bishop takes for example but
if you try to play for more with this
then after Queen e3 wow this position is
really becoming a little suspicious
because Queen e1 is coming and this is
just one example of how you don't want
to do definitely this is you got a porn
yeah but man did you sell your soul to
the devil here for that that's really a
very very bad idea so just one example
of many so in the game he decided to
play quietly Quincy won in top olives
defense we can say that he's being very
cautious for now but watch what happened
the bishop goes back to a 6-row k3
Bishop back to b7 tactical defense of
the pawn on a 7 because a Bishop f3
check and in this position again
efore f5 as we already know so 93 and
rooks e7 okay one defensive move is
defending the pawn not a5 Bishop a8 of
course black has no intention whatsoever
of trading his Knight for the bishop
with Bishop for the night and now again
many many variations I mentioned like
efore g5 with the idea of playing g4 and
if rooks c3 then g6 is excuse me again
g5 with the IDF chief or again the same
idea so he plays Knight c4 and black
plays d5 giving mentions that even g5
was possible but II 5 is the most
concrete nerve wanting to play E 4 at
the right time now in this position you
could see that top olive completely lost
his head he manages to play several
really bad moves and get into real
trouble
efore ok that's still normal that's not
in itself not a mistake
f5 ok but now he needed to really pacify
the situation he needed to plane ID chip
the best move was to play 92 then after
takes
takes and then we have two choices
either route before immediately or takes
takes root before this is of course
equal both sides have an ugly pole
structure in a not so safe king and in
the major piece ending you could already
see how this is going to Peter Peter out
either to a drawn rock ending or to some
perpetual check that would be very
normal and probably a fair result which
she could go home very happy that his
novelty getting got him a draw with no
effort against a very scary player
however atop olive is still not really
believing it and not really willing to
concede that he can just give a draw
with white like that and he plays this
move this is like the reason I chose
this game by the way if you want to know
is that in the World Cup
he had this game where in time pressure
he played the move F takes G six I don't
know if you guys saw it he was black
white and upon on g6 he played f take g6
and he got made it in just a few moves
just our reflexive move where if you
would have played f5 he would have
really almost no trouble in the kingside
to his seven think was defended and this
is also kind of a similar idea he just
simply decides to take a pawn almost
like with some oblivion just not really
appreciated in what was going on and of
course Vichy didn't need a second
invitation
efore is coming and men if you look at
the two positions you started to realize
that the white king not exactly where he
wants to be and look at this bishop on a
it's like from a distance he's selling a
nice telegram trouble is brewing it's
coming now he needs to super be super
careful but he makes another hasty move
and after that the game is just over and
which he finishes in classical style he
plays this suicide just suicide who
plays a move like this is unreal instead
of course he should have played
something like here here here were again
the pot on f3 along with the bishop
behind it you can tell I know who I want
to be in this position it's not very
difficult but again the burden of proof
is can that thing move can you really
advance your position who is under
attack you still have to do something so
Queen g5 yeah Black is better probably
is going to regain his pawn but I'm not
moving
that can play b3 I'm not moving my route
from after you and good luck to you
coming and mating me still a big task in
my opinion but of course black is the
one was playing for two results draw and
win however after this he's just playing
for one result after Queen takes here
and this is just look just optically
speaking I I it's really embarrassing I
mean the polyp comes here every year and
of course I know him and sometimes you
want to ask about this game but it's a
bit embarrassing because this is not his
shining moment but it's like what were
you thinking about when you took her on
f5 and then on e4 especially the need
for it so maybe to me it seemed like he
was just unwilling to say that he has
given a draw so easily in the decisive
game of the match and he said okay show
me
but he got shown and it's like it
doesn't look like it's that hard to be
shown here so after this rook D for now
Queen G for checkmate it looks very very
nice here so right here Queenie 8 I'm
guessing the table this is the move the
penis this is a monster move just when
you think the queen is in the center and
you think where can I go can I cannot do
anything on the diagonal and I can't go
do anything laterally but he just goes
back and now now I'm positive that top
olive understood that this game is going
it's going south and fast Queen h5 mate
is threatened and that there is no more
hope he played g4 to stop Queen h4 so h5
very very powerful the white king again
if I could put if I could play this I'm
actually in very good shape however not
really allowed so King age 4 and again
which she plays the most flashy
continuation yeah of course not h2 xg9
takes g4 and all of a sudden white is
like all over but Queen da check and f6
h g4 was good just very simple but he
decides to play here and again the white
king is just not having a good day
after takes Queen takes threatening rook
G for mate
so Queen f1 rook G for king h3 and okay
now you say very nice my rook on g4 is
great
my queen on g6 is great my bishop on a8
is very great and my rock on c7 is a bit
a bit of a pensioner right it's kind of
a retired so bring it into the game
plays the best move he could have played
King eight seven not to have to
calculate all those checks and funny
stuff but why bother
rookie seven Chuck here and Knight f5
check needless to say that if he takes
the bishop that dear bishop that we
talked about then wish she would have
not missed takes check and mate that
would have been probably very very fun
but now at that level it's not really
going to happen so we played Knight a5
check King eight seven needless to say
you cannot take the rook on f8 not
Knight xe7 check and the rook is coming
to the game and just know I'm not going
to happen
rook to g3 rook takes you got to take
with the pawn otherwise queen g4 is mate
so check and here winning the Queen and
normally you have some chances but here
you have no chances here now some people
said in this position remember on the
internet and URI also mentions it
some people were sure that White has a
draw here however now after Chuck Chuck
takes pawn takes very strong King takes
here here of course black is just
winning the pond ending so even though
he gives over the material his king is
just penetrating and this is an easy win
so no draw of course V she doesn't miss
things like that so keen takes G to
Queen here see for ya the rest is kind
of out of inertia ok many wins obviously
yeah
and in this position the night is gone
right or the work had begun in an even
just a lost position so top olive
resigned so again if you go with this
game in your database when you have more
time and you really look and you add the
computer you will really really
appreciate how perfectly Vichy played
this game really a masterpiece with
black home preparation a novelty get an
equal game his opponent is trying to do
something to make something out of the
game you still play every movies
accurate you combine caution with
grabbing opportunities and when your
opponent goes crazy with eat X F 5 and F
takes G 4 then he proved that the bishop
is just too strong for the for the night
and game over okay so this is our first
game our second game is even more wild
in my opinion probably one of the
wildest game in modern World
Championship and this is a game also I
think it was the last game of the match
between kramnik and Black Hawk in
Switzerland in 2008 was it or 2004 sorry
2004 in Greece agua thing so again this
is a game that I'm gonna do a lot of
injustice to because again my time is
limited I can tell you that this is a
game that if you haven't seen it before
if you haven't analyzed it carefully
before I very very strongly recommend
for you to do it at home with a computer
when you have a lot of time because the
possibilities behind the scenes that we
are not really going to be able to touch
and this goes also to the YouTube
viewers are just a pleasure this is like
it's like much of it is home preparation
you cannot go over all the variations in
a short time but again it shows you how
prepared peter lacquer was as a player
and he was really till this day is one
of the best irritations ever if he ever
decides to become a chess coach and
decided that he wants to help someone
even at the very top somebody's going to
gain a world of benefit from it also a
true gentleman by the way in a real
professional so gromek doesn't often
play an e4 e5 opening but he prepared
for this game specifically because he
knows that Peter always plays the
Marshall gambit the Marshall attack in
the Spanish in the Royal up
and he decided to say okay dude show me
what you got I'm going to take your pawn
and good luck to you trying to prove
that you can kill me definitely lots of
computer work here
lots of seconds work involved and many
hours so we go right into the table eeeh
okay so I don't know how many of you
know this position but this is a very
well-known position in the Royal Lopez
black gives up upon an idea of Frank
Marshall although Marshall didn't have
the idea of c6 he had an idea of my
level six a little bit different but
theory has evolved with the years but
the themes still remain the same you
give up the center pawn and you get tons
of activity I can tell you that at the
level of let's see below 2200 and
especially in scholastic chess
if I see a match between two guys who
are exactly the same rating who have
played let's say a million times and
have an even score I will always take
block always and anybody disagrees with
me I have money ready to prove it
honestly because this is just you've got
to be crazy at the club player level to
play like this with white no chances
whatsoever the attack is so hard to
repulse that even if you know 20 movies
of theory unmoved 21 you might just
stumble and if you'll be removed 25 or
30 watch watch where cranly goes wrong
here so g3 kind of a must I can tell you
already that at the Scholastic level
even one of my students who's in 1900
the first time she played this and the
last by the way because she will never
go into the marshal ever she will play a
4 or d3 when somebody castles she
already knows that she's programmed ok
she played h3 here and after Bishop
takes h3 there were lots of tears and
yeah so exactly this is just like you
don't want to do that and what can I say
here here
Ruki 4 yeah there are several moves that
are known in this position Queen f3
Bishop e3 92 all those moves where black
is white is trying to arrange some
defense and it's still in practical
terms it's very very hard maybe if
you're a grandmaster Allah has clearly
moved deep you'll find some drawer
somewhere but at the Scholastic level
they're not going to remember it they're
not gonna do it forget it and you're not
playing a computer so rookie 4 okay the
idea is very obvious I want to play at
some point like rook age 4 and just
shift everything so black has to play g5
again I'm not telling you this is your
conventional chest this is definitely
crazy chest
but it's really exciting this is really
fun just of course Bishop takes g5 is
out of the question because after Queen
a5 there's a simple fork and it's gonna
be awfully hard to defend both guys so
you cannot take it and he plays Queen f1
Queen h5 no way block is gonna treat
Queens when he's down upon with an ugly
pawn structure 92 and please don't ask
me the question what the theory is ten
years later because kill me if I know I
mean this is just impossible to follow
but again what I'm showing you this game
for it's just that the beauty of a the
preparation and also the the beautiful
ideas that that that are the test
preparation is so Bishop a5 f3 again
it's very well known that material has
different value in this position here
white is up a pawn and black already has
this pawn on g5 the pond it if the pawn
can go back to g7 don't be a different
story so of course when you take here
and I take all the attack is reposed I
have to agile bishops my pieces are
going to spring out I'm going to kick
your pieces back and leave this to say
that that's that's going to be really
great imagine something like Bishop
takes pawn takes e5 and then 94 and all
that stuff so yeah they give it a
questionmark period so Knight f6 the
knight is nagging the rock and of course
yeah dimension a4 is a possibility still
leaving the rock you can even take with
the knight but he decided to go back
again this is all preparation rook e8
you gotta take take and he played he for
a4 sorry yeah they mentioned Bishop d1
Queen g6 Bishop e2 is trying to regroup
and like playing some sort of a hedgehog
when I say hedgehog I mean just like the
animal is trying to get into himself but
he played a for preparation still Queen
g6 okay the attack of the H pawn and the
light squares here is done and now it's
time to use the free file the open file
and wide selection development of course
we want to play Bishop d3 followed by
something to e2 and things are becoming
very critical
I think already this position is very
suspicious for white but again I guess
the Cromley can his seconds and the
computer proved if you can play out play
it out but well okay
now let's see some analysis this is
supposedly the best line give back the
pawn and now been here ok this is
supposed to be some sort of a line I
mean one of those crazy lines that white
is supposed to survive I guess but again
black has nothing to worry about at all
here after Bishop d5 so he didn't do
that again because he's prepared for
something else he took on b5 and Bishop
d3 Queen f2 and that was the mistake now
it's the the line was would have been no
of course kind of an anti climatic to
play this here here and with the draw in
repetition of moves so that would have
been nice and again an achievement for
black who proves that there's no
advantage for whitening the variation
and therefore he can collect the half a
point to a black and then push with
white that's exactly the strategy in
matches but again Kramnik prepared
something and it looks really good by
the way
rookie 2 and of course takes takes takes
so this is the variation and I think
somewhere around here I'm not sure I
honestly don't remember kind of my
muffin because I didn't prepare it but
I'm not sure if Cromley expected the
next move or not or it came as a
complete surprise for him but somewhere
around here
Black Rose preparation is starting to
show so priority when you first look at
the position you think yourself what is
going on I mean why just looks really
happy here looks like black made some
mistake is like disarray and the point
is is jumping in but he played Queen d3
2 exclamation mark really really a
fantastic line king of two was played
and same idea Bishop takes f3
again very very a very strong idea with
with very few pieces
so he took 94 Chuck King he won and now
comes another motive Knight takes c3
threatening queenie to mate so the
knight came from one direction now he
comes from another direction just
imagine having this on your kitchen
table sometimes just analyzing with your
computers with your seconds and having
something I mean we're talking about
move 28 or something and it was like
yeah so it's very hard to stop the mate
if you don't take the knight so he took
the night and he took King f2 queen
takes a 1 so he could have still fought
on by playing Bishop takes g5 Queen
takes a 6 well needless to say that
black is in good shape having a queen
for 2 pieces you know only black is
playing to win but it's not that easy
because you know two bishops and a
knight can be somewhat tricky I think
that the human would have just suffered
here but against a computer maybe it's
trickier but in an event after this he
plays a7 and after 8 6 this was this was
to me kind of a funny moment because he
probably thought Queen takes a7
something takes g5 9 I think g5 but he
just says ok hey 7 he's not going
anywhere so you're not getting g5
anymore and now of course the position
is just over after h4 g4 Kramnik is just
realizing that he has he's gonna lose
the a7 pawn and under the circumstances
there's just nothing to play for and
resigned just an amazing game again like
I said I'm not doing any justice to this
game because we went over it relatively
fast we had some time constraints and I
have one more position I need to show
you but really a game that's really
worth going over it's game number 8 from
the recycled World Championship in 2004
Kramnik like oh ok can I fill this thing
okay our last example for the day and
again this is kind of a more well-known
because it's more recent and this is
from game nine of the anon Carlsen match
in the first one in 2013 in Chennai and
I'm not going to show you the whole game
but just going to show you what we can
define as probably one of the most
tragic moments in World Championship
history and I'm okay to do it because
before I show you a nun's brilliancy so
I can now give him a little hard time so
they played a team opening the turn up
into a very exciting attack a little bit
in this period the Bhavana kappa blanka
for those of you who know this game but
of course also very different so again
notice that I'm skipping all the
analysis because I want to go to that
position and okay in this position this
is at the critical moment he could have
easily drawn with 92 okay but he decides
to go for more okay for Queen and this
is the critical moment of the game and
you can see this on youtube like in like
in a car not live but a recording that
he took a little not that much time to
play the move Knight f1 and makes one of
his worst blunders of the of his career
he should have played Bishop f1 in this
position and after Queen d1 lukkage for
Queen h5 Knight takes pawn takes rook
takes Bishop f5 g6 completely crazy I
know but this is it's normal
Bishop takes here route g5 and again
lots of analysis Knight takes f6 pawn
takes f6 Queen takes f6 route d5 as you
can see the game goes on most likely to
a draw this equal right yeah and an
equal position and again many many
fireworks but at the end all the
material kind of evaporate just the
wholesale of trades and probably wish
she would have captain drama most likely
would have happened
similar to displaying 92 on this
position that would have been really
easy okay let me go to this variation
just for the sake of historical justice
after here here here here here here
and equality is going to be Queen f6 is
threatened so why is it a drawdown
because he plays what
now I'm curious white was supposed to be
a drop I say again nightly it may be
naive oh you can't do that because I'm
gonna make you you know so here I have
to what push my h1 I'm guessing right
I'm not sure my dad's manner I mean this
is not the point the point is not to
show you this the point is to show you
the what happened in this variation
after here Rock f4 here he played nine
f1 again it seems the same right it
looks like what is the difference
between this and this he played nine f1
and now he completely missed Queen e1 he
was probably expecting again queen d1
after which she will just play here here
here here
Knight here and just wins Knight f5 is
coming and he's just killing him but
that would have won the game however
what he did not cede it after Queen e1
it's all over because now of course
after Luke h4 Queen takes h4 there's
just nothing to look at anymore
he's just done a rock with no attack and
nothing so after some contemplation and
lots of his sad faces he had to resign
and yeah very decisive game in the match
- so terrible all right guys I think
this concludes our lecture for today
hope you enjoyed it